Megan rap you know the team captain who
said that she previously she's going to
retire after the end of the season she
had a penalty kick or a free kick or
whatever it is I again I'm not a
communist I don't watch soccer I don't
know what the rules are soccer was
invented by European ladies to keep them
busy while their husbands did the
cooking a chance to save the day for her
team and instead as her very last act as
a professional soccer player here's what
happened let's watch that together
honest to God I could do better than
that I really could I I've kicked a
soccer ball approximately zero times in
my entire life and I could do better I
really could